The prophet Muhammad sallallah.aii
wasallam told us that whoever builds a
mosque for Allah, Allah will build for
him a sim at a house in Jenna. And we
know the great reward that will not only
be gained but rather will fill your
grave after your death. Whenever someone
prays there, whenever someone gives
shahada in the masid, whenever someone
learns something in the masid, yes, that
will be something that you'll have on
your scale.
[Music]
How are you guys doing? After popular
demand, I decided to bring back
this man here who's to my left. A man
who needs no introduction whatsoever. A
man who has confronted the far right and
been humiliated by them.
a victim of the abuse.
>> Is he shy?
We're talking about
>> intellectually molested
>> needs da
>> that's me brother time that I've been
away
>> as you know the salah project
>> had to be there cuz we just moved in and
uh cleaning the place putting things in
order getting the team
>> to work in this uh efficient way so now
the team are doing well I tell I told
them
>> I've been eating off Tuesday is my day
off
>> I'm going back to the mandm
>> you have to do it
>> yeah I told him I'll come back there
Well, well, there's the man to the far
left to deal with the far right today.
And this is a man who has been on a
roll, I believe, in the last couple
speaker corn. Have you seen his videos?
>> Unbelievable. This guy is now he's
trying he's trying to take opposition.
This guy should
take position.
>> Maybe we should do what MA does and take
him out.
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Stepping on our toes now.
>> It's too much now. trying to destroy our
legacy.
>> But uh another person who's trying to
destroy our legacy or another two people
is a Ponzi scheme expert um pyramid
scheme um individual specialist um and
his compatriate from uh England.
>> Yeah. And pedophile apologist.
>> You think I'm joking? You think I'm
joking? I got video.
>> Okay, we'll come to that in a second.
>> I got video. Okay, we'll come to that in
a second.
>> They say every accusation is a
confession.
>> Okay.
>> They they called us a pedophile
apologist. Yeah.
>> Is that what they said?
>> Yeah, they did. But they have no
evidence for us. But we have evidence
for them.
>> Okay. We're going to come to them in a
second. But before we do that,
>> this guy's been speaking about us all
the time. He's got my name and your name
in the title, though. The video didn't
contain you at all. I don't know why he
put you in the title.
>> You know what it means? It means you.
They need you visually with me. My name
is
>> I don't need to be there. When they put
my name in the view, we didn't need to
bring videos. He done this. He done
that. We've made
>> Well, the guy was playing victim. He was
he was crying that, you know, he was so
upset that I sent him legal letters
through my solicitor.
>> No, no, no. He sent us to his kids
house.
>> Let's take a look at what he said and
come back and respond in kind. This is
Muhammad hijab. Okay. Which I don't
know. Have you guys ever met each other
or No,
>> no. Muhammad sent me recently. He thinks
he's clever. So, he said he's this was
to intimidate me. So, he sent legal
letters to my children's home. That's
what he did. Now he knows I don't live
where my children do. Yeah. So he sent
legal letters, but that was that was to
let me know because I was talking about
him that to let me know I believe for
him to let threatening me for where my
children are. So that's what he done. I
I sent the letters back within cuz he's
I I do my homework on everyone. So I
sent my letters back to his personal
address the next day. I just returned
them straight to him. Said, "Don't play
with fire, you muck." So he he is an
Islamist. He's a radical. He supports
And I come out and said he's a caveman.
And now recently again, he sent his
Muslim law firm have sent me all these
legal letters now again saying they're
going to sue me. But I said the same
like I've already been sued. I've been
bankrupt. I I said he's a he he's a
caveman who supports pedophilia or
apologizes for pedophilia. He's a
pedophile apologist.
>> I mean this is a pathetic thing, isn't
it? So what do I do if I want to take
him to court then?
>> Um I don't know.
>> I have to send it to where where do I
send the letters?
>> Send the pigeon. Where's my
>> even even the pigeon has to go somewhere
in it?
>> All right. Well, I don't even know be
honest. I don't even know where the guy
lives. And to be honest, it was just the
job of the solicitor to do that anyway.
That's just procedure, isn't it?
>> Well, it's silly, man. It's like the
arguments. It's like if I got a legal
letter to my house and let's say in my
house before there was a child that got
murdered and I go, he sent a letter to
my house when there was a little boy
that got killed before I moved.
>> What's that got to do? It's just the
thing is because he's been hanging
around Israelis and Zionists. this
victim mentality. That's right. That's
true. Anyone who's defending the cause
of Zionism, you can just see this, you
know, cringy disgusting victim
mentality. He always does this. He's the
same person. When I confronted him, he
would go to
>> Well, he never wanted to confront you,
did he?
>> No. No, he didn't. But I found him in
front of a court. I had him. I had to go
find him, bro. I was tracking him down.
I was trying to catch him in Luton
airport. I missed him, bro. He would go
to people's houses. That's right.
>> Screamed through the letter box. But
when I went near his house near a park,
>> he was like, "Ah, this jihadist is
coming, bro." He was bargaining out. So
you do it to others. But when I went out
of respect, I would go to your house. If
you lived in your house alone, bro, I'll
be knocking on your door. Out of respect
to your family and kids,
>> this man this man is a coward. Okay,
let's be honest. This is a guy
this is this is a guy, right?
>> He's in front of
>> We'll come to that. But this guy, Tommy
Robinson, let's just be honest. He's
he's attacking Islam all the time. When
was the last time you actually saw him
debate a Muslim?
>> No, he can't. He can't. Bro,
>> so why why if you want to be an
anti-Islamic apologist? Why don't you
debate somebody?
>> If you watch video, bro, his face color
changed when he saw me.
>> So, they can't deal with it. But with
them, it's on a microphone and a video,
etc. But what I find very ironic is he
accuses us of being a pedophile
apologist.
>> But if you look at look, every
accusation is a is a confession. Because
number one, firstly, let's be look,
let's put in perspective. If I go to
Google now and write
>> pedophile rings,
>> most likely the men that I'm going to
see that are going to look like Tommy
Robinson from age, from looks and it's
white middle-aged men. This guy is in
his mid-40s. He fits that profile
perfectly. Now,
>> even the Home Office report says that as
well.
>> Who are we talking? Who you talking
about? Are you talking about Tommy or
>> Tommy? No. I'm saying no, no, no, no.
I'm talking about I'm talking about
Tommy Robinson. I'm saying if you go and
Google and write pedophile rings, the
men that you will see there resemble
Tommy Robinson. M
>> they're white middle-aged men who are in
these acts and not only that we know in
his circles in the EDL they were
pedophiles.
>> Absolutely.
>> Is that yes?
>> We'll get into it. Yeah. In a second.
But we wanted to watch a video though.
So this video
>> because because this PBD guy has been
speaking about me for too long now.
>> Even though he's too scared to speak to
me. Why are you scared then?
>> He's a coward. He's a coward. You never
know. There might be a possibility I'm
not going to hurt you.
>> He might be on the list. He might be on
the list. He might be on the list.
>> I'm not going to hurt you.
>> He might be on the list, bro. You never
know because the way he's defending
Israel, he might be on the list, the
Epstein list. Yeah,
>> you believe he's there. It might be
>> may maybe they could possibly because
the way he's defending Israel. Now the
thing is now his co-host Adam who's an
Israeli is a is a Now check this out.
>> Listen to what he says and he's talking
about Peter Fel apologist,
>> bro. And check this out. You don't even
hear Patrick David speaking in this. No
way.
>> He's gone silent. Why?
>> Let's take a look at it.
>> I want accountability for everybody. If
it's Trump, if it's uh Bill Gates, if
it's Bill Clinton, I don't give a
If it's the president of anything,
expose them because Adam, the truth has
to come out.
>> Okay, good. He's consistent. Yeah. He's
saying which is just whoever they are,
whatever they are, let them get
arrested. Correct.
>> Guess what Adam has to say. Let's see if
he agrees or disagrees.
>> Adam. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Let's see if he agrees.
>> Is he an official host of
>> Yes, bro. Official. Official official
co-host, bro. Look how Patrick Davis,
he's not even speaking. Watch what Adam
says. Check this out now. Yeah.
>> Silence acquiescence.
>> Yeah. Watch this now. Watch this.
>> Okay. So, I only have one question for
you, my dear friend. I agree with you,
but at what price?
>> Take a deep breath.
>> But hold, hear me out. At what price? At
to what? Look, look, look, bro. There
there's pedophiles,
>> bro. The guy was flying out girls on
>> defending the perpetrators,
>> bro. He's defending the perpetrator and
he's saying
>> protecting them. In fact,
>> bro, just imagine if I said grooming
gangs. Yes,
>> we need to we need to expose them. I
agree. But at what cost? Bro, they will
hang me upside down in square.
When the police were thinking at what
cost you're going to be, you know,
there's that community. The far right
were adamant. It doesn't matter what
cost. At any cost, we must protect our
children. However, over here, who are
you defending?
>> As Muslims, do we agree at any cost they
should be brought to justice? Of course,
the groomers, the people, all of them.
Of course, but Adam say no. Now, listen
carefully. Watch this. Now,
>> any animal. So, you're saying to expose
whatever happened on Epstein Island,
you're willing to do whatever this looks
like?
>> Tear down the government, expose all the
secrets, put America basically in harm's
way just to find out what
>> do you mean, Adam?
>> Because these are the most powerful
people in the world, they're apparently
on this island.
>> Bro, he's basically saying because
they're the most powerful in the world,
>> they should be protected from uh
justice.
>> One sec. One second. And then, and then
>> they should not be brought to justice.
>> Sorry, sorry, sorry. One second, bro.
And Patrick Pet Davis is calling us a
pedophile apologist
>> and he's and this guy is the official
host.
>> Bro, his co-host is saying
>> and he's silent about
Hogan. Yeah. And he goes maybe we should
overlook it because
>> pedophiles. That's why they say every
accusation is a confession.
>> So you could say that he's you could
argue he's protecting the pedophiles
here,
>> bro. He's defending them, bro.
>> Defending the pedophiles.
>> It gets worse. Check this out,
>> Adam. Let the truth be told or the
heavens fall. I don't care. Yeah, Adam.
And that's who Vincent Oshana is. I am
100% accountability and I don't give a
if Adam if that's what we were built on.
>> What price?
America. Guess who the price is? Adam.
God. So you want a price? You're going
to answer them.
>> You want to rule a city of ashes.
>> I don't give a if it's built on
pedophilia and raping kids. Yes. Because
you're being emotional,
>> bro. Imagine if I said to you or someone
and I go, "You're just being emotional,
man. Let's look at the bigger picture.
Groom and gang here. They did this to
girls, but let's look at the bigger
picture. How it's going to affect Islam.
Let's let's turn a blend a blind eye.
Let's not talk about it, bro. Do you
know what that means? And you are
>> you're just being emotional.
>> Thank you. Imagine. Good. If I said
that, imagine he said that. Bro, they
would massacre us. Okay. I'm being real.
You have to understand the whole concept
of do you want to cut your nose off to
spite your face? There might be an
issue, but do you want to cut your whole
nose off and ruin your entire face
because you care that much about this
entire
>> He's basically belittling, bro. There
are pedophiles in America. There's a
documentary the return the return to uh
>> for geopolitical not Israel. What's it
called? The return of the right. There
are pedophiles running to Israel for
safe haven.
>> Okay. Now, one second. Tommy Robinson.
Yes. This man who fits a profile of a a
a pedophile. Let's be honest with you.
Now, this man is telling us about
pedophilia. My friend, you
>> mean by that? That many pedophiles are
like him. Not that
>> Yeah, of course. I'm not saying that
defamation.
>> Yeah. 100% 100% but he might send a
letter to my kids house.
My my 2-year-old baby.
Okay. So, he's that same guy who's
wearing a Mossad shirt.
>> What? What a contemptable junk.
>> No, no, no. Let's see. No, hold on a
second.
>> What a contemptable junkie he is.
>> Now, Zishan, you know very well the
connection between Epston,
>> his his rise to power, unqualified. Like
they say, it's not what you know, it's
who you know.
>> Hey, who he was working with. and he
worked his way up to a multi-billion
pound corporation of investments. Yes.
>> And who are these people, bro? So,
>> we don't know who these people are.
>> Can you touch up on a bit about that,
bro?
>> Epstein.
>> Epstein Islands and the connection to
the to Mo. Bro, look, I've got some Is
there anything that you have?
>> No, no, no. My stuff is going to
beaining EDL.
>> No problem. I'll just give you some
summary. Okay. It's my little not stuff.
Yeah. Okay. Um, Epstein was he went to
university. He was not a gradu. He had
no graduation. No um qualifications.
>> Reminds me of both of these men here.
>> Yeah. Not only that me definitely. Yeah.
The only thing is I didn't have an
island, a pedophile island. Okay. Okay.
He then got hired by Alan C. Grenberg
and he became a partner in six years
time to a corporation of multi-billion
pounds. Okay. He was not um even though
um Alan Cber was not an Israeli, he was
an American businessman born in Wikita,
Kansas and raised in Oklahoma City. He
was prominent figure in American
finances and most notably the former CEO
and chairman of Bur Sterns and was also
a major philanthropist.
>> Philanthropist
>> philanthropist. Thank you guys. For a
Jewish cause Jewish cause uh cause at
home in Israel. Okay. Now Jeff Jeffrey
Epson and Cole and um he started working
with someone called Less Wexner. Yeah.
Was the he was the only one who only
worked with Epson openly. Okay. And he
was someone that owned Victoria Secrets.
So, Victoria Secrets, you have these
models who come in and obviously, you
know, Victoria Secret, you know, the
underwear and all that kind of stuff,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Yes. No, no, no.
>> Yeah. So, so
basically what they say is that he would
use that um area. No, no, no. He would
use that to groom the girls.
>> So, these girls that will come to be
modeling etc., he would take them to
Highlands. Yes. Exactly. Now, Robert
Maxwell, Robert Maxwell was a Mosed
agent allegedly and his daughter Gizlane
Maxwell. Okay. Yeah,
>> Robert Maxwell was a prominent uh was
most prominent company was the Maxwell
Communication Corporation MCC which
which evolved from his acquisition of
the British Printing Corporation. He he
owned a few companies. He owned the
Daily Mirror. We know the Daily Mirror
newspaper. Yep. And he was involved
>> Victoria Secret.
>> No, it was Lex Wex.
>> Okay.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. Okay. Okay. And he was
involved in establishing Maxwell
Foundation after his death at the MCC
was sold. Is not to know that you can
cut this. Okay. Now check this out. When
he died, a mysterious death by the way.
Some say he had a heart stuck and fell
in the water and died.
>> They say suicide.
>> Okay. Okay. Yeah. He was buried in the
mountain of olives in Jerusalem which
was attended by six former Israeli
agents and then Israeli Prime Minister
Yizak Shamir said he's done more for
Israel than he can be than can be told.
Okay. His daughter worked closely with
who? Epstein. Okay. Now Ren Alexander
Austa is an American attorney and
politician. He said Epstein belongs to
the intelligence. Leave him alone. Now
there's more connections to be made. The
point is what? Who wore a t-shirt saying
Mossad? Tommy Robinson. Who promotes IDF
and Israel and Zionism? Who says I'm a
Zionist? Who says when what happens?
I'll be the first to go and fight Tommy
Robinson. And now he is promoting
Mossad. Mossad has direct connections to
the Epson Islands. Epson Islands was
used to draw in bring all these girls to
uh get these powerful men to blackmail
them and film them. Okay. So if anything
if anyone can be labeled with pedophilia
or pedophilia apologist is who Tommy
Robinson and not only that Patrick Pet
David his co-host Adam is belittling and
undermining and saying turn a blind eye
to the pedophilia and the girls been
being raped. So the point I'm seeing is
this you're accusing us of something
that like I said every accusation is a
confession. So to me it's ironic that
they dare to call us pedophile
apologists when this pedophile issue is
a white man's issue with all due
respect. Yes, it's not our problem. Must
have connection to the island, my
friend. You have no legs to stand on.
That's why at the end we're going to
give you a little challenge. But Dan, I
will pass it to you. I'll hold I'll hold
it for you.
>> Hello.
>> Hi.
>> Hello everyone.
>> Hi. Should I hold it for you more?
>> No. No.
>> Tell us more about the situation please,
bro.
>> So, what's more concerning is that look,
this is a issue. It's a problem the UK
is facing and frankly they're not doing
a good job protecting our children and
our women. Yeah, that's something that
goes without saying is statistically
backed. However, somebody like Tommy
Robinson is not the guy to be the front
of this. Yeah, he is somebody that has a
history of consistently ignoring or
defending, confronting pedophilia and
abuse within his own team. Yes, his own
team. Yeah, there are several cases. In
fact, there's been about 20 convicted
sex offenders that have been done for
child sex uh exploitation in his circle.
>> Is he con he's condemned them? No.
>> So that's the problem. Like 20 have been
affiliated with this in the EDL 10 under
his watch. Now this is according to a
hope not hate article. So it's all there
for you. You can check and cross
reference the names. They've got all the
references there. I'm just going to
mention a few so you guys realize that
this is not the guy that should be, you
know, the face of this movement. Why?
Because he still is yet to speak against
the very people from his own
organization that have been responsible
for this. The most prominent is his
close friend, somebody called Richard
Price.
>> He was his close friend.
>> Well, now he has now he has to pay the
price for this. world.
>> Richard, the EDL actually launched a
defense.
>> No way.
>> Yes.
>> Well, English defense.
>> No, no, no, no, no. PDF defense.
>> PDL PDL PDL.
>> It should be called that, frankly.
He just he just said, and these these
are direct quotes. Tommy Robinson was
saying he had been stitched up and Price
had no idea. no idea of what of these
indecent images of children appearing on
his devices. Finally, when he realized
that, you know what, this guy is going
further and further down the quicksand,
he tried to get out whilst kicking Price
in and he finally condemned him. Then he
lied by saying, "No, no, no, he had
nothing to do with the EDL or something
along these lines." However, there is a
direct quote of his from 4th June 2010
in which he said and I quote, "Myself
and Richard Price, we are the earliest
founding members."
>> So, the founding member of
>> PDL or EDL,
>> well, I think they should change it to
PDL.
>> EDL was the co-founder
>> and he had indecent images of children
>> and then EDL proceeded to defend that.
>> Wow. When they saw that they couldn't,
they tried to cut contact with him, but
that was clearly a lie. And I did
mention that there were 10 whilst Tommy
Robinson was still leading the EDL. Yet,
we are still to find a condemnation.
>> The grooming gang
you think about no no these these these
are grooming gangs.
>> That's what they are. You know,
>> worse than that, right?
>> Yes. And not only that, you know how
many of the those who attended the
protest on the the hotels, etc., There
were pictures of they were sex sex
offenders. Their pictures were bro the
pictures were saying hey this guy's come
here to condemn uh child and he himself
is a pedophile. He's a pedophile. There
was pictures taken like this one and
that one and that one. Every accusation
is a confession. That's the reason why
>> and not only that. So sorry Tommy
Robinson is talking to Patrick David
>> and he was interviewed before. You're on
a show that condones pedilia and defends
it. Bro,
>> what are you talking about? Let me ask
you something, Bob. We have Do you have
any connection to any pedophile at all
or bro? Not only that, his close friend
Liam Tuff, who invited me to his podcast
and changed his mind and I have to give
him I salute him for this. His dad is a
pedophile. He reported his own father,
Liam Tu, his left left hand man for
Tommy Robinson. Yeah.
>> His own father was a pedophile. Really?
Yeah. I give I salute him for one thing.
He reported his father to the police.
>> But imagine, bro, if argument sake, if
someone from my family member did that,
bro, these guys would use it to the
death of them. Yeah. So, subhan Allah,
if you look at it, bro, people that he
knows, people that he worked with,
co-founder of PDL, he's on a show that
>> Yes. Liam, he reported his own father.
>> Here's what we want Tommy Robinson to
do. Don't report your own father. Report
and condemn what Lee McMillan, who was a
senior EDL figure. If you can't do him,
what about Brett Moses?
>> If not him, what about John Broomfield?
If not him, Michael Coats. If not him,
Mark Archie Sleman. If not him, then
Matthew Woodward. If not him, then
Michael Kenna. These were people that
had links with the EDL. You might be
saying that's in the past. He's a
reformed and changed man. Ladies and
gentlemen, people reform party is
apparently not enough for Tommy
Robinson. That's why he is joining a Did
you know this? He's joining a political
party called Advance UK who's led who's
led by Ben Habib.
>> Pakistani guy isn't it?
>> Yeah. You know where he was born?
>> Pakistan.
>> He was in Pakistan.
>> Yeah. The very Is he going to tell his
people that the very grooming
>> you got to follow the Pakistani isn't
it?
>> The the very grooming gangs that he's
saying they're Pakistani.
>> His boss is a Pakistani now.
>> Yeah. They mentioned Pakistan. Pakistan.
Even during the speeches in this march
now. Well, apparently his father was a
Muslim. I don't know. Yes.
>> I I don't know. I don't know.
>> Yes.
>> But he's Tommy Robinson thinks and is
taking him as a leader. Ben Khabib, his
name is apparently he was told to start
this party off by Elon Musk who thought
um Nigel Farage in reform wasn't strong
enough frankly. So this is apparently a
new party led by a Pakistani. So I don't
know if you guys knew that. However, in
2017, and I want to end with this, he
shared a stage with William Charlton. He
ended up being a sex offender and having
indecent content. You can argue this
happened later on, but Tommy Robinson
shared a stage with him.
>> Good content, bro. Let me hold it for
you, please.
>> And and when he shared a stage with him
afterwards when finding this out, we are
still yet, this happened in 2017. were
yet to hear a condemnation. Liam Tuft.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. He condemned his own father.
>> You don't have to condemn your family.
>> Just condemn the people who you were
working with. Be consistent.
>> PP PDL. Okay. You know what? This was a
good comeback. After 2 months I've gone,
I think we had a really good strong
comeback.
>> I think it's going to send shock waves
around the the far right.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes. I think this was a very good
comeback. We destroyed them
intellectually
>> in all different ways. Alhamdulillah.
And um yeah, I think it was fantastic.
And we
>> It was good. I mean, look um to both of
these men, PBD and Tommy Robinson.
You've invited PBD has invited us to
come and debate two Christians
>> anti-Muslim Christians. They're not any
Christians, neutral in America. We
couldn't get into America with the visa.
We we deferred it to our colleagues in
America to deal with the matter.
>> But, you know, you can come to us at any
time. Tommy Robinson is a UK citizen,
right?
>> You can debate us at any time. You don't
need to keep speaking
>> um you know, behind people or passive
aggression. Be a man.
>> Yes. be if you think you have a case
against us,
>> just be a man. Be a man, you coward.
Both of you are cowards. The Ponzi
scheme p coward.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> And the contemptable junkie
>> called Tommy Robinson. Just step up.
>> You know, you speak to me, I speak to
you. We can speak about these matters
about Islam, about immigration, about
whatever. You will not have anything to
say.
>> Yeah.
>> You'll be corrected.
>> Exactly. If you have as simple as that.
>> If you have the guts, if you have the
gut. And it's not. Look, what have you
got to lose? You're Why you We're not
going to kill you. Exactly.
>> We're not going to hurt you. We're not
shooting you.
>> He only punches people.
>> He only punches that six-y old man. It's
not a fight. Exactly.
>> It's only a conversation. Why are you so
scared of a conversation?
You can speak. You can speak. You know,
do your thing. You know, we don't give a
damn.
>> We've clarified the points. You've got a
lot to answer for here. And don't ever
mention this pedophilia thing again,
considering your track records. Please
my friends
>> Hey, you are you wasting your time on
social media again? Your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a masid, a da center.
Establishing a masjid to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So that makes the reward
even greater. So give generously and
Allahel will give you even more.